so
oh
so
right
yeah
okay
okay
okay
[Music]
right
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank
did you sleep again
my
[Applause]
yes
hungry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
fuel
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
um
[Music]
i like
[Music]
[Music]
shhh
so
so
oh
god
[Music]
hey
hey
sidestep
[Music]
run
nice
ready step
oh
what time
ready stop
center
face
the congregation may stand as you are
able
with faith in jesus christ
we receive the body of our brother
robert joseph doe for burial
let us pray with confidence to god the
giver of life
that he will raise him to perfection in
the company of saints
deliver your servant bob sovereign lord
christ
from all evil
and set him free from every bond
that he may rest with all your saints
in the eternal habitations
wherewith the father and the holy spirit
you live and reign
one god forever and ever
amen
let us also pray for all who mourn
that they may cast their care on god
and know the consolation of his love
almighty god look with pity upon the
sorrows of your servants for whom we
pray
remember them lord in mercy
nourish them in patience
comfort them with a sense of your
goodness
lift up your countenance upon them
and give them peace
through jesus christ to our lord
amen
down
get up
work
alright
[Music]
application abc
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
smaller
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
yep
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mom
[Music]
[Music]
so
foreign
[Music]
russians
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i
hi boys
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i am resurrection
and i am life says the lord
whoever has faith in me shall have life
even though they die
and everyone who has life
[Music]
and has committed himself to me in faith
shall not die forever
as for me
i know that my redeemer lives
and that at the last
he will stand upon the earth
after my awakening
he will raise me up
and in my body
i shall see god
i myself shall see
and my eyes behold him
who is my friend
and not a stranger
for none of us lives to himself
and no one becomes his own master when
he dies
for if we have life
we are alive in the lord
[Music]
and if we die
we die in the lord
so then whether we live or die
we are the lord's possession
happy from now on
are those who die in the lord
so it is says the spirit
for they rest from their labors
[Music]
oh
mark
good
good morning
my name is randy hollares and i'm the
dean of washington national cathedral
on behalf of marianne buddy the bishop
of the diocese of washington
and michael curry the presiding bishop
of the episcopal church
welcome welcome to this house of prayer
for all people
we are honored to host this service for
senator dole
yet we recognize that we are gathering
yet again to lay to rest
a great american
only five weeks after having saying
farewell
to another icon in our nation
colin powell
we have indeed seen too much loss
in recent days
to elizabeth robin and the entire dole
family please know that this cathedral
and this nation
grieves with you and you are in our
prayers
bob dole was one of the greatest of the
greatest generation
a patriot who always placed country
above partisanship
and politics
while we mourn his loss we gather this
morning to give thanks for and to
celebrate his
extraordinary life
though senator dole has gone from us he
is not lost
the same god who raised jesus from the
dead will raise bob dole as well
that is the good news
our faith tells us that we will meet
again in a place where there is no death
no sorrow and pain are no more where
there is only life everlasting
this then isn't goodbye because in god's
story death never has the last word
for now it is enough to say on behalf of
a grateful nation well done good and
faithful servant
well done
thank you
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
wow
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
yes
[Music]
the lord be with you
and also with you
let us pray
oh god whose mercies cannot be numbered
accept our prayers on behalf of your
servant bob
and grant him an entrance into the land
of light and joy
in the fellowship of your saints
through jesus christ our lord who lives
and reigns with you
and the holy spirit one god
now and forever
amen
a reading from the prophet isaiah
do you not know
have you not heard
the lord is the everlasting god
the creator of the ends of the earth
he will not grow tired or weary
and his understandings no one can fathom
he gives strength to the weary and
increases the power of the weak
even grow tired and weary and young men
stumble and fall
but those who wait upon the lord
will renew their strength
they were sore on wings like eagles
they will run and not grow weary
they will walk and not faint
the word of the lord
so
clergy
distinguished guests
among many memories
from 50 years of friendship
it was one that especially captures what
bob goal
was as a man
and in my view as a patriot
we were on our way to the 50th
anniversary
of d-day
in normandy but we started in italy
in anzio
mucho has been written about
his time
in anzio
but to be there with him
felt
significantly different
he was on a mission in the mountains
nazi gunfire and mortar fire was thick
a man was dying men were dying
facing a hail of bullets
second lieutenant
robert joseph dole
hurled a grenade into an empty gun nest
he was trying to help a fallen comrade
his platoon radio men
when everything changed
and i mean everything changed
his spine was damaged
because
fire tore across the hills
shattering his body
grievously wounded
he was paralyzed
dragged behind a wall
bob would pass in and out of
consciousness
dreaming of home
as he laid bleeding in the foxhole
for nearly nine
hours
he was 21 years old
nearly eight decades on
we gathered here in a world far
different from the mountains battlefield
in 1949-45
but there's something
there's something that connects that
past and present
wartime and peace
then and now
the courage
the grit
the goodness
and the grace
of second lieutenant
named bob dole who became
congressman
dole senator dole
statesman husband father friend
colleague
and a word that's often overused but not
here a genuine hero
bob dole
dean
and the clergy officiating today's
service
president clinton
vice president harris vice president
pence and cheney and quayle
speaker pelosi
leader schumer leader mcconnell
members of congress of both parties
past and present
members of the cabinet
general milley
and leaders of our military
distinguished guests
most of all the dole family
elizabeth
it's been said that
memory
is the power to gather roses in winter
bob left you with 45 years worth of
roses
of a life built
and the love shared
that's going to guide you through the
difficult days ahead
jill and i will always be there for you
as many others in this church will be
as you and bob were always there for us
in ways nobody knows
and robin
you carry your father's pride
grace
and character
he'll always gonna be with you
because the old saying goes we irish say
you are your father's daughter
you are your father's daughter
bob dole's story is a very american one
born and raised in the three-room house
through the dust bowl of the great
depression
shipped out as a young
man to world war ii
wounded in battle
on the same weekend that franklin delano
roosevelt
was being mourned by millions
bob came home
rebuilt his life
painful hour
by painful day
by painful week
by painful month
by painful year
here he and danny noah
was wounded on the mountain not far from
where he was
talk about the recovery they spent
together for all those literally several
years
it was astounding
god what courage
bob dole had
he then went to school in the gi bill
came to washington with a new frontier
bravely voted for civil rights and
voting rights in the years of the
kennedys
lyndon johnson
and martin luther king jr
ran for president on ticket with gerald
ford through the ages of nixon
carter reagan
bush the elder and clinton
bob
was literally the master
of the senate
served together for 25 years
we disagreed
but we were never disagreeable with one
another
not one time that i can think of
i found bob to be a man of principle
pragmatism
and enormous integrity
he came into the arena
with certain guiding principles to begin
with
devotion to country
to fair play to decency
to dignity to honor
to literally attempting to find the
common good
that's how i work with george mcgovern
to fight hunger in america
particularly as it affected children
and around the world
he worked with teddy kennedy and tom
harkin
to bring down the barriers of americans
living with disabilities
a profound change
and profound act of grace
he worked with daniel patrick moynihan
to literally save social security
because bob believed
every american
deserved to grow old
with their basic dignity
basic dignity intact
and over the opposition of many his own
party
and some in mine
he managed to build to create the
federal holiday
in the name of martin luther king jr
bob dole
bob dole
did that
he never forgot
where he came from and never forgot what
he said
to our colleagues
about the effort for the king holiday
and i'll quote
he said no
first class democracy
can treat people like second class
citizens
no first class democracy
can treat people
like second-class citizens
bob didn't hate government
knew the people needed the most for the
people most in need
he wanted government to work
to work for folks like him
who came up the hard way
just give everybody a chance joe
just a chance
during the depression
bob's parents moved into the basement of
their three room not three-bedroom their
three-room
home
in russell kansas so they could rent out
quote the upstairs
bomb understood hardship
he had known hardship
they never never forgot it he never
forgot the people
as well who sent him to washington
people from russell from kansas
bob was a man who always did his duty
who lived by a code of honor
almost seems strange to say that today
but he lived by a code of honor
and he meant it
just as his colleagues republican and
democrat looked at him i think they saw
him the same way i did
just ask any who served with him at the
time
bob dole
fit my dad's description he said you
must be a man of your word without your
word you're not a man bob dole was a man
of his word
he loved his country
which he served his whole life
the bible tells us
too much is given
much is expected
and bob dole
for all his hardship believed
he'd been given the greatest gift of all
he was an american
he was an american
and he felt it
let's be honest
bob dole was always honest
sometimes to a fault
he once endured the wrath of his fellow
republicans
when there was a legitimate fight going
on to defund amtrak
now i've traveled over a million two
hundred thousand miles on amtrak because
i commuted every single day
it came time for literally to decide you
know
to deciding vote on whether we're going
to defund amtrak
and he cast the vote against his
party
deciding to keep funding amtrak
and obviously my guess he was asked why
why would you do that
he said it's the best way to get joe
biden the hell out of here at night so
he's not home no more
[Laughter]
[Applause]
excuse my language
true story
absolutely true story
god i love the guy
as i said he was always honest
but bob relished a good political fight
much as anybody i've ever served with in
the 36 years i was in the senate
and bob gave as good or better than he
got
he was a proud republican
he chaired his party
he led its caucus in the united states
senate
and he bore the banner
as its nominee for vice president
and president of the united states
he could be partisan
and that was fine
americans have been partisan since
jefferson and hamilton
squared off in
george washington's cabinet
but like them bob dole was a patriot
he was a patriot
and here's what his patriotism teaches
us in my view
as bob dole himself wrote at the end of
his life
and i quote him
i cannot pretend that i have not been a
loyal champion of my party
but i've always served my country
country best
when i did so first and foremost as an
american
end of quote
first
and foremost
as an american
that was bob dole
lydia that was your husband that was
your dad
always
as an american
he understood that we're all part of
something much bigger than ourselves
and he really did i felt
he really understood it
and the compromise
isn't a dirty word
it's a cornerstone of democracy
consensus is required
in a democracy to get anything done
that's how you get things done
again listen to bob dole's words not
mine
i'm quoting him again
i learned that it's difficult to get
anything done
unless you can compromise
not your principles
but your willingness to see the other
side
those is this those who suggest that
compromise is a sign of weakness
misunderstand the fundamental
strength of democracy
and the quote
in its final days bob made it clear
he's deeply concerned about the threat
to american democracy
not
from foreign nations
but from the division
tearing us apart from within
and this soldier reminded us and i quote
too many of us
have sacrificed too much
in defending freedom from foreign
adversaries to allow our democracy to
crumble
in a state under a state of infighting
that grows more unacceptable
day by day
grows more unacceptable day by day
he wrote this
when he knew his days were numbered
in small numbers
my fellow americans
taps is now sounding for this soldier of
america
forged in war
tested by adversity
taps is now sounding for this patriot
driven by a sense of mission
to give back to the land
that gave everything to him
for which he nearly gave his all
taps is now sounding for this giant of
our time
and of all time
we're bidding this great american
farewell
but we know
as long as we keep his spirit alive
as long as we see each other not as
enemies
but as neighbors and colleagues
as long as remember
that we're here not to tear down
but to build up
as long as you remember that
then taps
will never sound for bob dole
bob
will be with us always
cracking a joke
moving a bill
finding common ground
his final message to the nation
bob said that whenever he started a new
journey whenever he started a new
journey
the first thing he would do and i quote
is sit back
and watch for a few days
then
start standing up
for what
he thought was right and the quote
bob is taking his final journey
he's sitting back now watching us
now it's our job
to start standing up
for what's right for america
i salute you my friend
your nation salute you
and i believe the words of the poet r g
ingersoll
when he described heroism
better fit you than anyone i know
and ingersoll wrote the following
when the will defies fear
when duty throws the gauntlet down to
fate
when honor scores a compromise with
death
that
[Applause]
is heroism
the flights of angels
things that sing due to thy rest bob
god bless
bob dole
god bless america
and may god protect our troops
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my gosh
[Music]
[Music]
my
me
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mr president
[Music]
let's try that again
mr president
madam vice president
distinguished guests all
elizabeth
and robin
bob dole was a kansas native son
he along with his hero
dwight david eisenhower
are kansas's favorite son
and they represent the vision
and the promise
of america
in our state
molded bob and ike
open prairies
wind
always the wind
wheat fields
agriculture where man is at the mercy of
chance and weather
but can still be confident in the
dignity
of his labor
bob's early life in russell kansas where
the population hovered around 2000
included the dust bowl and the great
depression
bob characterized russell when
addressing the russell high school
graduating class of 1986.
he said
there are two kinds of education
in this world
there's one where you give yourself
and another you get from others
you can get an education on a farm or in
a factory or in a science lab in a
church pew
most of all
if you're from russell
you can get an education just by looking
at life
around you
when i was a boy
i doubt we knew the names
of our congressmen
or senators
but we were blessed to have friends
and neighbors
who knew and cared for one another
when times were tough
people were tougher
when the winds howled and part of the
prairie itself was blown away
i could barely see to deliver the
newspapers on my paper route
but because i came from russell
because i came from kansas
i was granted a special vision
one which has seen me
all the years since
one which you can rely on
just the same
and he defined this kansas vision by
saying
my friends i hope that you will never
stop looking at the stars
i hope you will never forget our state
motto
to the stars
through difficulties
i hope that you will never stop
believing in things you cannot see
i hope that your future is as hospitable
and beckoning as mine was when i stood
on a similar platform more than 40 years
ago
i hope
that in the making of life for
yourselves
you won't neglect serving your country
most of all
i hope that wherever you go
and whatever you do
russell will go with you
and for then
i know that you will be
well guided
and well guided
he was
in attaining his vision and embodying
the promise
of america
when we lost bob on sunday
there was a pause
throughout the state of kansas
as kansans from all walks of life
stopped to reflect
bob dole was a person who meant
something to everyone
in the coffee shop the campaign trail
the halls of congress
whether we were in topeka
abilene wichita or dodd city
i saw bob dole
connect with kansans always on a
personal level
he would share with them this vision
this promise
and he would help them
to achieve it
just like the folks in russell did in
supporting him
now
a young staff
and later a member of the house of
representatives
following in senators footsteps
i certainly understood bob dole's
influence and power
on a thursday
in 1983
he would be fighting to protect social
security with president reagan senator
moynihan others
in the white house and then on saturday
he would be listening to thelma
in sharon springs kansas
telling him that social security meant
to her
daily life and pocketbook
and when he returned to washington with
that empathy of his and knowing kansas
and knowing
thelma
it enabled him to win the victories that
he did for the disabled
for veterans
for the hungry or for any of the issues
of the day that needed
negotiation
steady compromise and the vision
of america's promise
bob never lost his common sense and
famous wit
it was embedded in his nature to deliver
that punchline
deadpan
knowing waiting for the room to light up
which it always did
for the barriers to come down
letting the air out of the partisan the
partisan balloons
those manner in influence were so strong
that if i were for something
people thought bob was for something
and i never informed them or bob
otherwise
well the work we did was serious
it was a different time
there were light-hearted times too
i would call up his chief of staff
and say
where's my speech
and the scramble was off to get the
leaders uh remarks
they eventually figured it out it was
roberts again and i made sure my staff
didn't take calls from toll's office for
the rest of the week
when his official public service came to
an end
bob could have faded
away with his dear elizabeth
telling stories
remembering remembering the good old
days
but that was not his nature
there was still so much vision and
promise still so much he could do for
his fellow veterans and for his nation
let everyone know
without bob dole
there would not be a world war ii
memorial
bob also stressed at the time that there
should also be a memorial to ike
so that veterans could salute
and thank their commanding general
that effort took 24 years
and again with bob's help
we dedicated the eisenhower memorial
last year
bob dole understood that it was just not
recognition
that this greatest generation
deserved it was reflection
and renewal
and it was for the greatest generation
to inspire the next generation
there is no better display of the vision
and promise of america
then every weekend when the honor
flights would roll up to the world war
ii memorial
kansas veterans
escorted by kansas high school students
would visit
their memorial
to reflect on their fight
to preserve a free world
and there was bob
shaking every hand
posing for every picture listening to
all the stories
and the thanks
the thanks of a still grateful nation
when elizabeth
told us he passed in his sleep
and we all knew
that an error had come to an end
my first reaction
was one of sadness
and grief
losing a dear friend
and mentor
but then thinking about it
i think the good lord touched bob's hand
and told him it was time to come home
see his folks
that there were quite a few world war ii
veterans and some from korea and vietnam
who were looking forward to thanking him
as well as folks who were disabled
quite a few
dogged cat lovers
and quite a few folks from farm country
still upset about something
and a whole passel of folks
from kansas and all
over
a lot of them republicans who say they
voted for him and some democrats who say
they should have
and then he said don't worry bob
our heavenly gates
are guarded by united states marines
so thank you lord
for enabling us to live in such a time
and space
that gave the offer us the opportunity
and privilege to know bob dole
a kansas star
who truly
shined
through difficulty
[Music]
so
uh
[Music]
mr president
madam vice president
distinguished guests
elizabeth
robin
i'm honored
i've always thought
that life has no blessing
like that
of a good friend
and to know bob
was to know the truth of that statement
bob's friendship was a blessing
that enriched my life
beyond measure
his dedication to public service
his determination
to keep washington and
congress places
of civility
and his kindness to linda and me
made our friendship a blessing
as rich
as life lovers
when i arrived in the senate in
1987
bob was literally
one of the very first people
to reach out
[Music]
we served on the finance and agriculture
committees
together and almost from the beginning
we seem to have similar views on
agriculture
nutrition many other issues
bob faced the world
both its cruelties
and his kindness
with humility
with
humanity and of course
with humor
i remember my very first appearance with
bob after we were both elected leaders
in 1994.
he was at a reception
where he noted that my election was
received with great enthusiasm
in farm country
because for the first time you had two
senate leaders from farm states
he said every farmer in america that
very weak
ordered a new tractor
and bob set the bar for me and
i suspect many others
when you share that story about when he
first came to congress
a reporter asked
what his agenda was going to be
he said i'm going to sit and watch
for just a couple of days
and then i'm going to stand up
and do what's right
and that's exactly
what he did
as the president noted
he stood up for minorities early in his
career
when he broke party ranks
and voted for the landmark civil rights
and voting rights acts
he stood up for the elderly when he
worked with pat moynihan
literally to save social security
he stood up for the young
when he worked with my
fellow south dakotan george mcgovern
on nutrition assistance
and he stood up for the disabled
when he worked with
ted kennedy and tom harkin
on the americans with disabilities act
and boy did he stand up for his fellow
veterans as pat just noted
as the chairman of the world war ii
memorial campaign
i know from many conversations how
important that accomplishment was he
even remarked to me once
thought about being buried there
well that may not be his final resting
place
i think bob
every single time i visit
of course these are all the things that
made bob dole great
but as bill rogers once
put it in one of bob's favorite saints
it's great to be great
but it's far greater
to be human
almost everyone
has heard
the bob dole
stories of
amazing heroics
and his recovery from injury in world
war ii
but few know the bob dole
who called the florida dentist in 1993
to encourage him after losing his right
arm
and help him find a specialist
to get a prosthetic on
and few people know the story about bob
dole
and the detour he took in his
presidential campaign in 1996.
he was in indianapolis
and he left the campaign for a few hours
to attend a graduation party
for a young girl
become paralyzed
because of a car accident
or as pat already noted
the bob dole
who waited at those airport gates
for honor flights
to greet veterans with a salute
and i thank you
he touched many people through his small
acts of kindness
including me
he taught me a lot when i became senate
leader
but the teaching didn't end
when i left the senate
when i lost my election in 2004
once again
bob was one of the very first
to offer me his guidance
and his support
he helped me find a speaker's bureau
he encouraged me to join him
at his law firm
it's a decision i never regretted in
part because it gave me the opportunity
to spend a lot more time with him
i can't help but think of the first time
i said farewell to bob
is when he left the senate in 1996
i remember he quoted a poem
by carl sandberg
in his final speech on the senate floor
i tell you
the past
is a bucket of ashes
i tell you yesterday
there's a wind
going down
a sun
dropped in the west
i tell you there is nothing in the world
only an ocean
of tomorrows
a sky
of tomorrow's
bob didn't always have an easy life
faced some har yesterday's
physical
political
personal losses
but for all he did lose
he never lost himself
he never lost his sense of humor
he never lost
his sense of integrity
he never lost his love for his hometown
russell kansas
or his deep deep love
for elizabeth and robin
and he never lost his hope
for tomorrow
his life was a testament to will rogers
truth
that the things
that make us human
the laughs we share
the burdens
we bear
can make us great
so
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
i will
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
give us
[Music]
as
we forgive
and
lead us not into temptation
but deliver
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
so
so
so
food
this is
i stand here
with a heavy heart
and also as a grateful
and proud daughter
i have had an incredible 67 years with
my dad
not many people get that time and i'm so
thankful
i will be brief today
to help me make it through this
and to make dad smile
because a lot of us in this room
know how much he appreciated brevity
i want to start by thanking all of you
for being with us today
i think i can speak for elizabeth when i
say the outpouring of love
and respect
is so heartwarming
we are
truly lifted
by your presence
and thank you mr president for your warm
remarks
i'll always treasure your recent visit
to dad and elizabeth and i at the
watergate
it was wonderful and i loved listening
to you share
all your
stories about the time you served
together
and i want to say thank you to his
extended family
and now mine
former colleagues
former staff
current staff
members of his household
elizabeth staff who i've gotten to know
really well this last couple days
the brunch
crew all of his visitors and friends and
family who called him regularly
he so enjoyed his time
with all of you
i want to say thank you
to his medical team
and believe me it was quite a team
his team on the east coast
and the west coast
for your dedication and for giving us so
many wonderful years with dad
especially this last year
we can't thank you enough
finally i want to thank his caregivers
i will be eternally grateful to you for
providing
extraordinary care
and compassionate care to my dad
and for always answering my many calls
and texts with grace
there were a lot believe me
the last years have been such a gift to
me
i feel so fortunate i was able to spend
hundreds of hours with my dad
and talk to him almost every single
night on the phone
we talked about everything under the sun
he told me things i never knew
he asked about my life about my friends
lives we made lots of calls to family
to former colleagues in the senate and
in the house to former staff
he shared feelings he had had not shared
before
with many of these people
it was a wonderful experience for me to
listen to these conversations and such a
gift
to them
and to dad
my dad is the most generous person i
have ever known
he was a giver
not a taker he cared more about others
than he did about himself
he told me he set a personal goal
to help at least one person every day of
his life
then he said
i'm not sure i've been able to meet my
goal
i said dad you've got to be kidding
some days you help one person and other
days you help 40 000 people
i think you've met and exceeded your
goal
well
you may be right he said
there is no one who helped
there is no one he helped more than me
he's always been there for me through
thick
and through thin
he always had my back even when i made
mistakes and believe me i made
quite a few
he believes in giving second chances and
i know that first hand
he was my rock
my dad was an animal lover
and we share that love
you've heard a lot about his work in
animal welfare but i'd like to share a
few personal stories
about his love for animals
when i was a little girl
my cousins and i would visit his parents
in russell every summer
grandma would often have animals for us
to play with
one year when i got home i cried and
cried
because i didn't know what would happen
to the little kitten that i played with
and grew to love
dad left on a trip to kansas
and much to my surprise
he brought the kitten home with him on
the plane for me
we named the kitten rusty because he
started in russell
recently i lost my dog cooper
dad was the first one to call me
he consoled me and he said all the right
things
the support that support meant the world
to me
soon he began to encourage me to get
another dog
quite frequently he encouraged me to get
another dog
and i tell him i just don't know
if i'm ready but he kept encouraging me
and eventually
he got me a puppy
and i wanted to name my puppy after dad
but you know i didn't want to name him
bob
so i decided to name him jojo
after
his middle name joseph
and we visited many many times dad
always wanted me to bring jojo with me
which wasn't always easy but we did it
and dad always wanted me when i got
there to hold jojo up so he could get
kisses from jojo i'd hold him up to his
face
and dad always wanted elizabeth to get
kisses too
and
jojo
did a very good job
spreading his love
dad and elizabeth's dogs blazer and
leader were always trotting into his
room
they loved to visit
but it was blazer who was the most
concerned about him
blaze would lay at his feet whenever he
suspected dad needed special
nursing care
and i believe it really helped him
because he loved them so much
when i was preparing to speak today
i learned about a farewell letter
dad wrote with a former
staff member
none of us knew that he had written this
letter he swore him to secrecy and he
kept a secret
the joke is you may move on to other
jobs
but once you're a dole staffer
you're always a dole staffer
and a lot of people in this room know
that
i'd like to share in closing
part of that letter and i encourage you
all to read it in its entirety
it has been released to the public as he
wished
here are his words
as i make the final walk
on my life's journey
i do so without fear
because i know
that i will again
not be walking alone
i know that god will be walking with me
i also confess that i'm a bit curious to
learn if i am correct in thinking that
heaven will will look a lot like kansas
and to see like others who have gone
before me
if i will still be able to vote in
chicago
[Laughter]
i do have one request to make a view
since i was dedicated excuse me since it
was
dedicated in 2004
it has been my honor to go as often as i
could
to the world war ii memorial here in
washington d.c
to welcome and thank the world war ii
veterans and all veterans who are
visiting there
since i won't be making that visit
anymore
i hope that you will
and that you will ask your children and
grandchildren to visit veterans
memorials across america
and to never forget the sacrifice
made not just by my generation
but by all those who wear the uniform of
our country
my final words are the exact ones that
dwight eisenhower used to conclude his
speech
in abilene nearly seven decades ago
i believe in the future of the united
states of america
i will miss him
so much
i think i will still talk to him every
night
i love you dad i promise
you will never walk alone
thank you
now
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
readings from the new testament
and one of the scribes came up and asked
him
which commandment is the first of all
jesus answered
you shall love the lord your god with
all your heart
with all your soul
with all your mind and with all your
strength
the second is this
you shall love your neighbor as yourself
there is no other commandment greater
than these
love is patient
love is kind
it does not envy
it does not boast
it is not proud
it is not rude
it is not self-seeking
it is not easily angered
it keeps no record of wrongs
love does not delight in evil but
rejoices with the truth
he who does not love
does not know god
for god is love
the word of the lord
mr president mr madam vice president
distinguished guests
and dole staff
having served
with senator dole for 20 years i am
honored to read a poem by linda ellis
that senator dole often included in his
speeches in later years
i believe we will hear in these words a
description of the man whose life whose
leadership
and whose legacy we celebrate today
i read of a man who stood to speak
at the funeral of a friend
he referred to the dates on the
tombstone from the beginning to the end
he noted first
came the date of the birth and spoke the
following date with tears
but he said what mattered most of all
was the dash between the ears
for that dash represents all the time
that they spent
life on earth and now only those who
love them know what that little line is
worth
for it matters not how much we own the
cars the house the cash
what matters is how we live and love and
how we spend our dash
so think about this long and hard
are there things you'd like to change
for you never know how much time is left
that still can be rearranged
if we could just slow down enough
to consider what's true and real
and always try to understand the way
other people feel
be less quick to anger
and show appreciation more
and love the people in our lives like
we've never loved before
if we treat each other with respect and
more often wear a smile
remembering that this special dash might
only last a little while
so when your eulogy is being read
with your life's actions to rehash
would you be proud of the things they
say
about how you spent your dash
president biden
vice president harris
distinguished guest
beloved
elizabeth
and thank you robin for reminding me
that your dad
loved brevity
i grew to love
my brother in christ
robert
joseph dole
i'm entering my 19th year in the senate
and one of the high points
though i came after
the honorable robert dole had left was
to
meet
elizabeth
elizabeth is one of the most ethically
congruent
people
i know
to know you is to love you
i
know the many phone calls
and how
i have been blessed
by our friendship
your spirituality dwarfs
my own
but
it rubbed off on bob
i used to have flirted rendezvous with
bob in this very cathedral
so many memorial services he was here
sometimes pushed in a wheelchair
but i would at the end of the service
bolt
around the side of
the cathedral for our rendezvous
at the fore
we
really got to know one another well
particularly
uh when we were
i was
able to work with him on the world war
ii memorial and
learn so much from this
great patriot
as i listened to the readings
i thought about him
what an appropriate reading
for the old testament
isaiah 40 31
they that wait
on the lord shall renew their strength
they shall mount up with wings as eagles
run
[Music]
and not be weary walk
and not faint
i used to wonder did did we get that
right it seems it should be run
and not
faint walk and not be weary but
the pedestrian and prosaic
movements of life
can often push you
to the point of fainting
far more than those
emergency moments with the adrenaline
rush
and then
what a beautiful passage for the new
testament
love
agape
understanding creative redemptive
good will for humanity
which
describes
the life and legacy
of
robert doe
i'm still working on calling him bob i
still can't do that
i remember
elizabeth when we had the conversation
and you put bob
he said let me put bob on the phone and
i had the beatific experience of
having a conference call
with spiritual royalty
and at the end
i had a sense
that bob
knew
he
was cared for
by a great shepherd
so i'd like to toss in
another verse
psalm 23
verse 4.
even though i walk through
the valley
of the shadow of death
i will fear no evil
for you
are with me
your rod
and your staff
they
comfort me
i believe my beloved brother in christ
knew he was cared for
by a great shepherd
a shepherd who said in john
10
11 i am the good shepherd
the good shepherd gives his life for the
sheep
bob was
a covert spiritual agent
he did not
wear
his religion on his sleeves
he resonated with the sentiment of
francis of a [ __ ]
preach the gospel everywhere you go
when necessary
use words
he believed
the sentiment of edgar guess i'd rather
see your sermon
than hear it any day i'd rather
it should walk with me than merely
tell the way
this
covert spiritual agent believed that
he was cared for by a great shepherd
who left
the chance
of
cherubims and seraphim
and a rainbow encircled
throne in a land where night never comes
to make a breakthrough at
bethlehem
to see about
bob
to see about you to see about me
and he could say
even though i walk through
the valley
of the shadow of death
i will fear no evil
for you are with me
he knew
i firmly believe elizabeth he knew that
there was brevity
as robin put it in that valley
i'm not going to be walking around in
that valley i'm not going to be having a
picnic in that valley yea though i walk
remember they will walk and not faint
where ye though i walk
through
it's temporary
he knew that he was not in that valley
to stay
for second corinthians 5 1 says if this
earthly tent that we live in
is
destroyed
praise god
we have a building
not made with hands
[Music]
eternal in the heavens
he knew that
he knew
that there was light in the valley of
shadows you cannot have shadows without
light to project the shadow and
he could say with the psalter in the
27th psalm the lord is
my light
and my salvation whom
then shall i fear
he served a savior who said i am the
light of the world
but there was one other thing he knew
he knew
he knew that there was comfort
in that valley
and and we've talked about this day
coming
he knew there was comfort for us
that shepherd
he loved so much and we loved so much
once said
matthew 11
27 and onward come unto me all you who
labor and
are heavy laden and i will give you rest
take my yoke upon you and
learn of me for i am meek and lowly in
the heart
and you will find rest
for your souls
[Music]
for
my yoke
is easy
my
burden
is light
i remember when you told me that he died
in his sleep
and i said what a transition
and those words of
william cullen bryant immediately leap
to my mind for
he was telling us how we should aspire
to transition
he wrote so live
that when your summon comes to join that
innumerable caravan
where each must take his chamber
in the solemn halls of death
go thou not like the quarry slave
scourged to his dungeon at night
but sustained
and soothed
by an
unfaltering trust
here it is here's bob
approach thy grave
as one who wraps the drapery
of his couch about him
and lies down
to pleasant dreams
my brother
in jesus christ
red quiesca
in pachi
rest
in peace
oh
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
three
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
for our brother bob let us pray to our
lord jesus christ who said
i am resurrection and i am life
lord you consoled martha and mary in
their distress
draw near to us who mourn for bob
and dry the tears of those who weep
[Music]
you wept at the grave of lazarus your
friend
comfort us in our sorrow
you raise the dead to life
give to our brother eternal life
you promised paradise to the thief who
repented
bring our brother to the joys of heaven
[Music]
our brother was washed in baptism and
anointed with the holy spirit
give him fellowship with all your saints
comfort us in our sorrows at the death
of our brother
that our faith be our consolation and
eternal life our hope
father of all we pray to you for bob and
for all those whom we love but see no
longer
grant to them eternal rest
let light perpetual shine upon them
may his soul
and the souls of all the departed
through the mercy of god
rest in peace
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
we
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
give rest of christ to your servant with
your saints
we're sorry are you in the lord
now
you only are immortal
the creator and maker of mankind
and we are mortal formed of the earth
and to earth shall we return
for so did you ordain when you created
me saying you are dust
and to dust you shall return
all of us go down to the dust
yet even at the grave we make our song
alleluia alleluia alleluia
thank you
christ
your servant with your sayings
for sorrow and pain are no more as a
sign but life everlasting
into your hands o merciful savior we
commend your servant bob
acknowledge we humbly beseech you
a sheep of your own fold
a lamb of your own flock
a sinner of your own redeeming
receive him into the arms of your mercy
into the blessed rest of everlasting
peace
and into the glorious company
of the saints in light
amen
now go forth into the world in peace
be strong and of good courage
hold fast to that which is good
render to no one evil for evil
but love the lord your god
love your neighbor
love yourself
the blessing of god almighty the father
the son and the holy spirit
be on you and remain with you in this
world in which we live
this day
and forevermore
amen
let us go forth in the name of christ
so
oh
ah
[Music]
when you walk
through a storm
hold your head up high
and don't be
afraid
of the dark
[Music]
cause an endless storm
there's a golden sky
[Music]
and the sweet silver sounds
of a lark
walk on
through the wind
walk on
through the rain
though your dreams be tossed
and blown
walk on
walk on
with hope in your heart
and you never
walk alone
you never
[Music]
[Music]
with hope in your
heart
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
just my children and my wife
thank my lucky stars
to be living here today
cause the flag still stands for freedom
and they can't take that away
[Music]
the men who died who gave that right to
me and i gladly stand
up next to you
and dipping her still today
[Music]
god bless the usa
[Music]
from the lakes in minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from sea to shining sea
from detroit to houston
go over new york to l.a
there's pride in every american's heart
and it's time we stand and say
[Music]
that i'm proud to be an american
where at least i know i'm
won't
free
the man who died who gave that right to
me and i gladly stand up next to you and
defend her still today
cause there ain't no doubt
i love this land
god bless the usa
[Music]
and i won't forget the men who died who
gave that right to me
[Music]
god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yourself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ready
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ready
step
ready step
ready
step
ready
step
ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
face
[Music]
ready
[Music]
[Music]
oh
five
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
nevermind thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
oh
today
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
good
[Music]
i know
[Music]